whether it's bending minds as the leader
of the x-men selling out his friends and
colleagues as a corrupt official or
serving his personal physician to a
dictator james mcavoy has incredible
range omitting voice roles tv movies and
cameos james mcavoy's filmography comes
out to a very impressive 29 credited
roles
keep watching to see how we've ranked
them all from worst to best warning this
video contains fast flashing images
viewer discretion is advised especially
for those with photosensitive epilepsy
german filmmaker vim venders is known
for classic arthouse films such as buena
vista social club and wings of desire it
is a shame that his 2017 romantic
thriller submergence sinks like a stone
to the very bottom of this list james
mcavoy stars as james an mi6 agent who
falls for the deep-sea obsessed
bio-mathematician danielle played by
alicia vikander pedal from
the greek haters meaning unseen doesn't
it mean hell
submergence is handsomely shocked but
overly long essentially becoming two
different films once james and danielle
leave the scenic french hotel where they
meet unfortunately neither story is
interesting james stares at the walls of
his cell danielle stares at her phone
rinse and repeat ultimately the lack of
chemistry and good dialogue between
mcavoy and vikander dooms the film their
short tryst isn't believable as an epic
love story surviving torture or a
near-death experience at the bottom of
the ocean submergence is one cold fish
while not taking the worst spot on this
list dark phoenix was the biggest box
office bomb of 2019. the final mainline
x-men film from 20th century fox was the
second attempt at adapting the beloved
dark phoenix saga storyline from the
marvel comics the first being the
disastrous x-men the last stand in 2006.
the x-men engage in a space rescue
mission only for jean grey played by
sophie turner to bond with the cosmic
phoenix force magneto and professor x
portrayed by michael fassbender and
mcavoy respectively fight over her fate
as mysterious alien invaders plot to
take the power of the dark phoenix for
themselves x-men producer writer and
first-time director simon kinberg had
originally intended dark phoenix to be a
two-part epic however rewrites resulted
in a film that wasn't the space opera
fans expected combined with weak
villains and a seemingly checked out
cast we're left with a film running on
fumes despite an uplifting epilogue
where professor x and magneto reunite
and settle their differences with the
game of chess dark phoenix is the last
gasp of a once mighty franchise
at the start of victor frankenstein igor
the titular mad doctors hunchback
assistant played by daniel radcliffe
tells us that we know this story so why
tell it again borrowing characters
visuals and plot elements from previous
adaptations the only meaningful change
in victor frankenstein is who is telling
the story that's the easy part done easy
part
when frankenstein played by james mcavoy
meets igor he's a circus clown and an
amateur doctor after they save the life
of an injured aerialist they become
scientific partners in victor's
dangerous tampering with the forces of
life and death victor frankenstein
embraces the hidden homoeroticism of the
concept of two men trying to create a
new life and it gives the cast plenty of
pulpy scenery to chew but what kind of
frankenstein movie introduces the
monster only in the last 15 minutes
despite mcevoy's ferocious performance
victor frankenstein is dead on arrival
mcavoy is no stranger to the horror
genre but his first brush with the dark
side of cinema was 2001's the pool one
of the countless slasher movies made in
the wake of scream this unimaginative
flick is notable only for featuring
mcavoy and isla fisher as two teenagers
who meet the wrong end of a machete set
in prague the pool follows a group of
international students eager to make one
last splash before graduation when they
are attacked by a killer in a skull mask
the pool is a by the numbers slasher no
one will be surprised when the
characters split away from the group
just so they can die quicker or the
killer's deeply misogynistic motivation
you know the pool has nothing original
to say when it includes the actual line
i know what you did last summer
m night shyamalan's 2000 feature
unbreakable has developed a massive cult
following for its original take on the
superhero formula 16 years after its
premiere fans were excited when the
ending to shyamalan's feature film split
revealed that the movie was a secret
sequel shyamalan completed his trilogy
with 2019's glass bringing together each
film's protagonist for the first time
in front of the world
in the 19 years between unbreakable and
glass superhero narratives have gone
from nerdy niche to blockbuster fodder
shyamalan subverts the genre in glass
making a superhero film that feels
deliberately underwhelming even
alienating to its audience ultimately
whatever statement the film was trying
to make about superheroes becomes
pointless as david ehrlich said in his
film review for indiewire the trouble
with glass is that its mildly intriguing
meta textual narrative is so much richer
and more compelling than the asinine
story that shyamalan tells on its
surface although many including
shyamalan were impressed with mcavoy's
performance that alone couldn't rescue
the film
my son gives james mcavoy one of the
most challenging roles of his career as
a father investigating the disappearance
of his young son he was also the only
actor on the set of the 2021 mystery
thriller not given a script left up to
largely improvise his performance which
created a unique experience where the
audience uncovers clues and deciphers
the mystery at the same time the actor
does director co-writer christian
carrillo adapted my son from his 2017
french film of the same name which would
give one hope that he had ironed out the
kinks of such an unusual production
mcavoy gives a naturalistic performance
capturing a father's confusion anxiety
and rage but the film doesn't have much
to offer audiences aside from the
central gimmick my son could have been
groundbreaking but it's only
conventional
it's the early 1980s and mcavoy's
professor x dresses like he's on miami
vice as he instructs a new class of
super students meanwhile the ancient
mutant and sabonur played by oscar isaac
under pounds of blue makeup seeks to
rule the world i
have returned
x-men apocalypse has its charms such as
when evan peters quicksilver returns for
a rescue scene set to the music by the
band eurythmics but brian singer's final
film in the franchise he launched in
2000 is uneven and overstuffed even die
hard x-men fans will groan at the film's
many detours including the obligatory
wolverine cameo somehow holocaust
survivor magneto destroying auschwitz
out of grief and rage is in the same
movie with cody smith mcphee's
nightcrawler wearing michael jackson's
jacket from thriller they may save the
world but for the x-men this film is a
sign of the end times
welcome to the punch is a standard
shoot-em-up starring mcavoy as max
lewinsky a cop still dealing with the
effects of being shot by career criminal
jacob sternwood played by mark strong
several shootouts follow all leading to
a final confrontation at the container
yard known as the punch mcevoy and
strong are excellent foils to one
another but their sparks aren't enough
to light up this derivative cops and
robbers movie it's a shame because one
wonders what the two leads could have
done with a more interesting script
welcome to the punch is a decent time
waster for action junkies but not much
else
also released under the title rory
o'shea was here the 2004 irish dramedy
inside i'm dancing stars mcavoy as the
titular rory o'shea an irrepressible
rebel who lives with duchenne muscular
dystrophy he befriends the introverted
michael played by stephen robertson who
has cerebral palsy but this being a kind
of inspirational film tragedy inevitably
strikes 18 years after its release
inside i'm dancing deserves scrutiny for
casting two able-bodied actors as the
disabled wheelchair using rory and
michael as andrew paul rang a disabled
writer said of the issue in forbes what
to some viewers seemed to be deeply
empathetic and almost athletic feats of
acting to others in particular many
actual disabled people seem more like
showboating and mockery the film
attempts to address ableism in ireland
including the difficulty of finding
affordable accessible housing but inside
i'm dancing undermines its message with
problematic casting and a sappy
stereotypical story
christina ricci plays the titular
penelope a young woman born with a pig
snout as a result of a witch's curse
with her snout hidden under a colorful
scarf she falls for mcavoy's johnny
marsh a red-blooded gambler while her
wealthy parents arrange for a rich
suitor to supposedly break the curse god
you licked me edward what don't lick max
penelope is an eccentric fairy tale that
helped cement mcevoy's status as a
romantic lead viewers watching today
will be star struck by the supporting
cast which includes catherine o'hara
richard e grant reese witherspoon and
peter dinklage the actors gamely play
along with the film's quirky plot and
uplifting final message about
self-confidence but there may be a limit
to how many pig jokes they can make
robert redford's 2010 period drama the
conspirator explores a little-known
chapter of american history the trial of
mary sarat who is played by robin wright
mary's son john was one of the
conspirators behind president abraham
lincoln's assassination and because mary
owned the boarding house where john and
his accomplices gathered she was also
charged as a conspirator you were one of
lincoln's pallbearers too how can you
represent her she's entitled to a
defense freddie
so i shall defend her
in the conspirator mcavoy's frederick
aiken is a lawyer who doesn't want to
defend surat in court she is a proud
southerner and he was injured fighting
for the union in the civil war but after
meeting mary and her daughter anna
played by evan rachel wood he becomes
convinced of her innocence it isn't
often that a movie based on true events
has a red carpet screening at the scene
of the crime but the conspirator was
shown at ford's theater in washington dc
the site of lincoln's assassination a
bold choice but one that reflects the
overall staginess of a well-acted but
sometimes boring film a perfect movie
for high school history teachers to show
their students and sometimes that's
enough
becoming jane joyfully mixes fact and
fiction to tell the story of novelist
jane austen played by anne hathaway and
her brief love affair with mcavoy's tom
lefroy an irish lawyer set before she
wrote her groundbreaking novels austin
is living in the country her life is
upended by the arrival of lefroy and in
true romantic novel fashion sparks fly
the chemistry between hathaway and
mcavoy carries this light but
bittersweet film particularly in a dance
sequence full of smoldering romantic
tension perfect scenery and beautifully
detailed costumes add to the film's
elegance watching it is like having tea
on a lovely sunday morning dedicated
austin fans may object to becoming jane
favoring a fictionalized love story over
her literary achievements but the film
makes an argument for laphroaig
inspiring mr darcy the romantic hero of
austin's pride and prejudice
they don't make rom-coms like 2004's
wimbledon anymore the movie stars paul
bettany is peter an aging british tennis
pro who intends to retire after the
upcoming wimbledon tournament an
unexpected romance with vivacious rising
star lizzie played by kirsten dunst
reignites his love for the sport however
her father played by sam neil sees him
as a distraction that could ruin her
career in one of his early supporting
roles james mcavoy delivers comic relief
as carl peter's cyclist brother who bets
against his games hold on hold on isn't
he playing your brother
you should be ashamed of yourself yeah
but curiously i'm not
wimbledon is as pleasant and uneventful
as a warm bath and betany and dunst are
charming as two pretty blonde people who
fall in love it doesn't break the mold
but in an era where mainstream
theatrically released rom-coms are an
endangered species wimbledon becomes
something special
it was the horror blockbuster of 2017
and currently ranks as the highest
grossing movie based on a stephen king
novel telling the story of derry maine
the home of the otherworldly clown
pennywise and the losers club who try to
destroy it director andy muscati chose
to adapt the book in two parts it
chapter 2 picks up with the adult
characters 27 years after the first film
what
push i'm pulling [ __ ] oh
thanks
james mcavoy inherited the role of bill
the leader of the losers club and now a
successful horror novelist he reunites
with his friends including jessica
chastain's bev and bill haters richie to
perform the ritual of chud and end
pennywise's threat forever it chapter 2
is dragged down by a bloated 169 minute
run time and a plot overflowing with
aggravating detours while it has a
strong cast and scary surprises it
chapter 2 can't quite recapture its
childhood glory
based on evelyn was 1930 novel vile
bodies stephen fry's 2003 film bright
young things chronicles the lives of the
idol rich as they delve into parties
alcohol and sex adam played by stephen
campbell moore wants to marry social
climber nina portrayed by emily mortimer
unfortunately customs officers
confiscate the novel he has staked their
future on calling it pornography mcavoy
plays the aristocratic and bohemian lord
simon balcam
a small but significant character as he
is the face behind mr chatterbox
london's most notorious scandal column
simon stark quickly falls when he's
caught crashing the wrong party and
facing social ruin commits suicide
though he exits at the halfway mark
mcavoy's presence lingers over the film
as adam only inherits the mr chatterbox
column through simon's death beneath the
glitz and glamour of bright young things
their lurks a terrible human cost
as an actor james mcavoy is not afraid
of taking on unusual or challenging
roles the disappearance of eleanor rigby
is three films in one chronicling the
decaying marriage between mcavoy's conor
and his wife eleanor played by jessica
chastain
the disappearance of eleanor rigby her
and the disappearance of eleanor rigby
him tell the same story from each point
of view a fight between conor and
eleanor in one film could have an
entirely new context in the other
creating a unique viewing experience
director ned benson also pieced him and
her into a single film subtitled them
that tells conor and eleanor stories in
a single linear timeline them is the
most conventional of the three with
jason bailey noting its incompleteness
for flavor wire it's a very good film
but throughout it it's phantom limbs
tingle hinting that it was something
much more special before its
frankenstein job what could have been a
novelty project emerges as a deep drama
about two people who come together come
apart and maybe come together again for
those who can commit to multiple movies
be prepared for a rewarding experience
no one can say that 2013's filth doesn't
live up to its title mcavoy stars is
bruce robertson a corrupt cop who brings
pain and misery wherever he goes when
his usual vices aren't enough bruce
tramples his way through edinburgh his
mental state fracturing into disturbing
hallucinations and things only get worse
from there i used to be a good person
yeah
i heard that
filth is an endurance test sprung from
the mind of ervin welsh the author of
trainspotting the film is manic
self-indulgent raw and savage if the
audience isn't hiding behind their hands
they won't be able to take their eyes
off james mcavoy in a performance
completely stripped of vanity mcavoy
plunges into the darkest parts of
bruce's soul revealing the terrible
losses that sent him into a
self-destructive spiral lest the viewer
think spilth has gone soft it saves the
cruelest joke for the very last scene
mcavoy simon is a fine art auctioneer in
danny boyle's 2013 featured trance who
believes that art is not comparable to
human lives the human wreckage left in
the wake of a botched artist seems to
prove him wrong in this wild
psychological thriller simon somehow
engineers a switch of a priceless goya
painting before it's stolen but after
getting a nasty blow on the head during
the heist he can't remember what he did
with the original oh yes trans is an
amnesia movie from spellbound to memento
amnesia is an advantage to psychological
thrillers especially ones about how the
slipperiness of memory shapes our
identities simon seeks out the
hypnotherapist elizabeth played by
rosario dawson to unblock his memory but
when she learns what he's trying to find
she wants a piece of the action but what
else is simon hiding in the depths of
his mind boyle's film is full of pulpy
nightmarish excess to the point where
reality seems to bend rewriting memories
and personalities at will did you ever
dream about waking up one day and
finding out that you're not an ordinary
joe working in a cubicle that you're the
lost heir to a secret fraternity of rich
beautiful assassins and now you can do
anything you want this geeky power
fantasy comes alive in 2008's wanted
loosely based on the comic series of the
same name by mark miller and jg jones
wanted shifts away from the comics
nihilistic tone and cheap shocks relying
much more on kinetic escapism mcavoy in
a role originally modeled after the
rapper eminem gets the action movie
equivalent of a cinderella makeover he
seamlessly transforms from a sweaty
anxious schlub into a leather jacket
wearing dual wielding elite assassin
wanted also gave mcavoy and future
guardian of the galaxy star chris pratt
their first roles in a comic book movie
making it even more hilarious when
wesley slams a keyboard into his
obnoxious co-workers face
the last station accomplishes a rare
feat it spins a vital engaging film
around the subject of copyright law the
2009 feature is set in 1910 focusing on
the final months of iconic russian
author leo tolstoy played by the late
great christopher plummer tolstoy
preaches ideals such as pacifism and the
abolishment of private property and
considers signing a new will that would
put all of his writings in the public
domain however his wife sophia portrayed
by helen mirren who bore him 13 children
fears that he is robbing his family of
their rightful inheritance despite good
cause for it
i've never stopped loving you of course
but god knows you don't make it easy
woven into this family conflict is
tolstoy's private secretary valentin
played by mcavoy young and idealistic
and prone to sneezing fits valentin
realizes that his literary idol is not a
god but a flawed man who doesn't always
practice what he preaches helen mirren
owns the film with her explosive
performance as sophia a woman who sees
straight through tolstoy's suck-ups and
bristles at her husband's betrayal
2003's bollywood queen was the first
time james mcavoy stepped into the role
of romeo in a modern reimagining of
william shakespeare's romeo and juliet
but not the last thankfully he isn't
playing a cartoon gnome here he's jay a
guitar strumming lad from somerset who
falls in love with gina played by priya
khalidus a british indian girl who loves
bollywood musicals bollywood queen is
bright and splashy fun given its
inspiration it's not a shock when
characters start dancing and bursting
into songs both in hindi and english
cletus and mcavoy are cute as the couple
caught in the clash between two very
different families just try to resist
their meat cute when their love at first
sight is so powerful that they both
begin to levitate
based on the first installment of cs
lewis's beloved children's fantasy
novels 2005's the chronicles of narnia
the lion the witch and the wardrobe
follow the four pevensey children as
they evacuate london during the blitz in
world war ii when they travel to a
countryside mansion containing a
mysterious wardrobe the pevensey clan
are transported to a magical world
overtaken by the white witch played by a
chilly and terrifying tilda swinton and
ultimately join the fight for the fate
of narnia
every stick and stone you see
every icicle
is narnia
james mcavoy plays mr tumnus a
kind-hearted fawn in a red scarf it's a
role that's so memorable that mcavoy
reprised it in 2019 for a saturday night
live skit mcavoy gives tumnas a gentle
charm in his scenes with lucy pevensey
who is played by georgie henley in her
first on-screen role his performance
gives us the first signs of warmth in
this strange world condemned to eternal
winter
split is m night shyamalan's 2016 take
on the super villain origin story
combining hitchcockian suspense with
old-fashioned exploitation movie grit
split is about mcavoy's kevin wendell
crum a man struggling with dissociative
identity disorder and
23 alternate personalities vying for
control of his body this psychological
thriller is a spectacular showcase of
james mcavoy's acting abilities and
would arguably not work without him at
its center mcavoy must play eight
distinct personalities with different
ages speech patterns and mannerisms with
only minimal costume changes and he
rises to the challenge a major point of
concern however is how split portrays
dissociative identity disorder mental
health professionals and persons with
did criticized the film upon its release
for villainizing mental illness so
viewers should keep that in mind given
kevin's portrayal as someone dangerous
and violent though his capability to
crawl up walls at least pushes split
into the realm of pure fantasy
charlize theron goes straight for the
jugular with her stiletto heel and
atomic blonde this 2017 spy thriller
stars theron as lorraine an mi6 agent
with an attitude as icy as her white
blonde bob lorraine is sent to recover a
microfilm list of every active british
agent in cold war berlin there she
becomes entangled with mac voice
percival a crooked mi6 agent who may or
may not be the kgb spy codenamed satchel
don't shoot i've got the shoe
atomic blonde has all the ingredients of
a classic spy film stolen microfilm car
chases through european cities double
and triple crosses and even an alluring
french agent played by sophia butella
theron is fearless and at this point in
his career james mcavoy has perfected
the role of the fire-eyed scoundrel john
wick director david leach brings his
neon soaked bloody knuckled magic to the
film including an intense 10 minute
single take fight scene that ends with
an escape set to a flock of seagulls the
style gives atomic blonde its substance
2007's atonement is as beautiful as it
is devastating what begins as a story
about the forbidden love between working
class robbie turner and wealthy cecilia
talis played by mcavoy and kieran
knightley transforms itself into
something greater a meditation on war
love and yes atonement nightly and
mcavoy are perfect as the thwarted
lovers conveying a lifetime of desire in
every small glance and hidden touch in
what is arguably his greatest
performance as a romantic lead mcavoy
portrays a man who carries a memory of
love from the once idyllic talis estates
to the devastated shores of dunkirk
atonement also delivered him a much
deserved golden globe nomination for
best actor
foxx's x-men films were in trouble
following the double disappointments of
x-men the last stand and x-men origins
wolverine but in true x-men fashion it
took a trip to the past to save their
future matthew vaughn's 2011 feature
x-men first class was a soft reboot for
the struggling series taking the team
back to the 1960s the era in which stan
lee and jack kirby created the comics in
the months before the cuban missile
crisis fassbender's eric lencher is a
metal manipulating nazi hunter and
charles xavier is a groovy telepath and
academic when the two men meet their
lives and the world are changed forever
mcavoy and fassbender lead the x-men
franchise into a new era and form the
emotional core of the four prequel
movies
the brutal dictatorship of ugandan
president idi amin is viewed through a
stranger's eyes in 2006's the last king
of scotland james mcavoy plays fictional
scottish doctor nicholas garrigan who
travels to uganda in the 1970s for
medical missionary work while there he
inadvertently charms his way into
becoming the personal physician and
confidant of the brutal and
unpredictable amine played by forrest
whitaker in his academy award-winning
performance director kevin mcdonald
brings his experience as a documentarian
into the last king of scotland giving it
a hazy discomforting sense of reality
whitaker is a towering presence and the
sydney morning herald commented on
mcavoy's turn as garrigan stating mcavoy
is dark and wiry and displays a nervy
egocentricity that is not particularly
likable does no damage to the film on
the contrary it helps to explain why he
should be so susceptible to a means
flattery
starter for 10 is an unquestionably
british coming-of-age story mcavoy is
brian a floppy-haired university student
in the 1980s who loves the television
quiz show university challenge while
trying to impress his university
challenge team brian's love triangle
with a flashy blonde and a feisty
brunette played by alice eve and rebecca
hall respectively may be too much of a
distraction this man has been sent from
the offices of university challenge
the film offers its fair share of 80s
nostalgia new order and kate bush are on
the soundtrack after all but mcavoy's
winning performance as a would-be trivia
champ gives starter pretend its vitality
prepare to be blindsided by how funny
this film is where else can you see
james mcavoy literally butt heads with
benedict cumberbatch and knock himself
out
the x-men film series arguably achieved
its greatest success with the 2014 time
traveling epic x-men days of future past
inspired by chris claremont and john
burns comic story of the same name which
has been continually ranked amongst the
best x-men storylines the film also saw
the return of director brian singer to
the franchise he departed after x2 x-men
united in the not-so-distant future
civilization is overrun by sentinels
advanced robots designed to hunt down
mutants the x-men have one last plan to
save the world send wolverine's mind
back in time to his younger body once
he's there he can reunite mcavoy's
professor x and fassbender's magneto and
stop jennifer lawrence's mystique from
committing the assassination that will
launch the sentinels x-men days of
future past combines mutants machines
and the plots of a 70s political
thriller to produce one of the best
films in the superhero genre amid the
star-studded cast featuring original
x-men cast members and new faces there
is one standout performance that
completely reinvents a role the
atlantic's review put it best writing
mcavoy is the real star of the show
put aside the time travel giant robots
and muted angst x-men days of future
past is the story of one man learning to
hope again check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and
stars are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]